Thanks, Rado.
Now that we know the distinct
advantages of using a list view,
we can use a list view to display the list
of weather forecasts in our app.
Now which file in the layout folder
should we modify to accomplish this?
Well, we want to add the list view
directly to the fragment.
If you open up the fragment_main.xml file,
you'll notice that the layout includes
a RelativeLayout as a parent view,
as well as a child TextView.
Modify this file so that we show
a ListView instead of a TextView
and assign it an ID ListViewForecast
so we can reference it later.
Also, since this layout only contains
one child's view,
it would be more efficient
to actually switch to a FrameLayout
instead of a RelativeLayout.
After you make the changes,
compile and run your app.
You will be a little bit underwhelmed
with the blank screen, but that's okay.
That's because we haven't populated
the list view with data yet,
and that will come in a later step.
Check the box when you're done.